[Musique]
électrique
je rentabilise puisque ma moto mécanique
que j'utilise vraiment vraiment c'est
une bonne chose j'aime bien ça
[Musique]
et nous avons des milliers de motos
électriques en circulation et nous
sommes également dans plusieurs pays de
l'Afrique sur le plan écologique comme
vous le savez les motos électriques ne
polluent pas l'environnement sur le plan
économique nous avons pu réduire le coût
des motos électriques en faisant
l'assemblage localement
[Musique]
c'est une très bonne moto
disons c'est très économique et il y a
pas à faire une vidange il y a pas
remplacer certains moteurs et autres il
suffit seulement de d'échanger la
batterie tu vas au niveau bon il y a des
points de vente vous allez là-bas et on
vous échange ça et c'est amis prend
l'unité
[Musique]